morning what are you doing  showering my third of the day I like to  stay extra fresh just in case emergency  sex pops up this is an employer locker  room ah look I get it  standing in here with me all naked suds  DUP you're thinking to yourself wow that  is the last climber to summit Mount  Chanel how am I supposed to compete with  that  look Chad I'm a surgeon a brilliant you  check out two boxes on the dateable guy  checklist handsome and rich and guess  what I check those two okay first of all  I have never heard that checklist so I  call bull crap on that existing oh it  exists second did you just call me  handsome just given the circumstances  that's a little weird  you